deep in the jungles of Central America  one question has confounded mankind for  centuries why did the Maya civilization  suddenly disappear from the face of the  earth  an astonishing new discovery has finally  provided the answer these ancient  carvings tell us the Maya were invaded  by alien killer robots  the robots employed a variety of  advanced weaponry to attack one another  and they were equipped with  technologically superior targeting  systems when the time ran out they  unleash devastating attacks to rebuild  their shattered defences they drop  blocks of earth from the skies then once  again annihilated their enemy even more  astonishing life researchers also found  evidence of den killer robots ancient  gods conquistadors climate change killer  plants and even evil snowmen this is  without doubt the most important  historical discovery of our time join us  as we learn the full destructive power  of the Mayan death robots